[Music]
okay
great
[Music]
okay
good evening ladies and gentlemen
my name is ed fulner i'm the president
of the heritage foundation
once again i'm pleased to welcome you to
another in our series of
lectures under the general theme of
varieties of conservatism
as some of you may know this is a four
part series
the other participants in the series
include carl gershman
former executive director of the social
democratic alliance of the united states
under the title of why i am not a
conservative
the next in this series will be
professor shirley letwen
professor letwin a political theorist
and social critic from cambridge
university in england will speak on the
subject why i am not a libertarian
and
mr george gilder
the program director of the
international center for economic policy
studies in new york city
will speak on the subject why i am not a
neo-conservative
tonight's
speaker a noted traditional conservative
if i may categorize him
is dr russell kirk
dr kirk first came to prominence with
the publication of the conservative mind
in 1953
since then he has authored several
scores of books
he has been a
newspaper columnist he is still an
active columnist for the
journal national review
his
other involvements include
his service as editor of the university
bookman for many years
and a trustee of the intercollegiate
studies institute
and i am very pleased to say also as the
current distinguished scholar of the
heritage foundation
tonight it's our great pleasure to
welcome dr russell kirk
who will speak to us on the conservative
movement then and now russell
[Applause]
i thank you for those kind words sir
any virtues which my remarks tonight
have
uh
are owing to
mr o'sullivan uh who
suggested the lions might
talk to follow and all the vices are
mine
i believe these remarks of mine are to
appear eventually in print and policy
review
well in some 30 minutes i'm going to try
to deal with
conservatism
today and yesterday and i look forward
to the comments of our two distinguished
colleagues here
in the united states as in britain
the passage of some
three decades is required
for a body of convictions to be
expressed discussed
and at last incorporated or rejected
in public
policy ordinarily the slowness is the in
the movement of public opinion
is to the nation's advantage
by contrast with the
mercurial politics of france say
is the devil who always hurries
however that may be
in america nowadays it appears
such a fruition of ideas
is about to take form
i mean that we are entering upon a
period of conservative politics and
policies
in this republic
in both the great
political parties i suggest conservative
views will tend to dominate
men and women who profess conservative
convictions will be elected to office
as suggested by last night's primaries
and what matters more the conservative
political imagination
will set to work to allay our present
discontents and to
renew our order
for a thoughtful renewed conservatism
begin began to appear in print
at the end of the 1940s and the
beginning of the 1950s
with the publishing of books and
periodic periodical writings by men of a
conservative bent
i'm now editing by the way i am to be
called
the viking
uh portable conservative reader
and have to reflect on
really who started this recent revival
and i decided that richard weaver is the
man in 1948 who really begins the
revival of conservative thought in the
country
ideas do have consequences as richard
weaver wrote about that time
and now a generation later
those conservative concepts popularized
are about to enter into practical
politics
now it doesn't signify that most
so-called activist conservatives
may have read only scantly if at all in
the serious conservative books of 30
years ago
that is to be expected
serious thought always is vulgarized and
filtered and transmuted
through newspaper editorials and sunday
sermons and college lectures and
paperback books and even television
programs
until a crowd of people perhaps wholly
unaware of the sources of their
convictions
come to embrace a particular view of
religion or of morals or politics
as henry adams remarked in his education
during his editorship
the north american review had only a few
hundred subscribers
but he found his journal's views
plagiarized happily in hundreds of
newspapers
thus the average american citizen will
have no notion
that his vote in 1980
has been moved in part by certain books
three decades old which he never has
opened
nevertheless it will be so
incidentally
a few of my colleagues here tonight i
may mention that the
it seems to me over the past 30 years
the most influential magazine has been
harpers
for good or for ill
under various editors and one can phrase
the direct connection between ideas
expressed in harpers and those expect
reflected in public policy especially
the supreme court
a few years later
this was a surprising fashion
well
similarly it does not signify that some
of the writers who have moved mines in a
conservative direction
do not call themselves conservatives
this is especially true of europeans
residing in america
the historians eric vogelen and john
lucac
we are concerned not with ideological
tags but with practical influence upon
informed opinion
now i'm suggesting that the present
conservative movement in america
commenced as an intellectual development
in this like the fabian movement in
britain which also required some 30
years for its fruition in public policy
but unlike the tightly concerted fabian
society
the american intellectual renewal of
conservative ideas beginning around 1950
was perfectly unorganized and undirected
the work of isolated individual scholars
and men of letters only slightly
acquainted with one another's work let
alone enjoying personal acquaintance
take the names of men whose books
obtained some attention perhaps as
novelties
shortly before or after 1950 richard
weaver daniel boyston peter burick
francis wilson william buckley
when i published my book the
conservative mind in 1953 i had never
met any of these gentlemen except weaver
nor had they met one another with but
few exceptions i believe
besides no two of them agreed perfectly
about anything not even about the word
conservative
nevertheless the gender of whom sydney
hook calls ritualistic liberals
i took this recruit essence of
conservative opinions for a wicked
conspiracy
a rumor went around among professors of
history for instance about 1954 that
daniel boersten peter burick and russell
kirk were plotting industriously to
dominate the teaching of history in this
land
actually no one of us had ever set eyes
on the other at that time
until this renewal of conservative
thought at the end of the forties
liberal dogmas in morals and politics
had everywhere been
been triumphant in the united states
since the 1920s as lionel trailing still
declared with some misgiving at the end
of 1949.
irving babbitt and polymer moore have
been dead for years
donald davidson and alan tate were read
as poets and critics only
in practical politics the leading men of
both parties unemployed murdered the
vocabulary of latter-day liberalism
including herbert hoover
yet as if tripling's remark had conjured
spirits from the vastly deep
no sooner was his liberal imagination
published and the literary adversaries
of liberal dogmata
rose up in numbers
in the book review media and weeklies of
opinion at the beginning of the fifties
it was the fad to refer to these writers
as
new conservatives or neo-conservatives
prefix neo usually implying the contempt
of the commentator
recently at the end of the 70s the
epithet neoconservative has been clapped
to yet another set of opinions of
writers and scholars
or are these new
neoconservatives really another set
some of them certainly are recruits or
converts to a conservative view of
american society
but a chief man among them irving
crystal in london there's editor of
encounter at the beginning of the 50s
actually has not changed his views in
any important respect
during intervening three decades
he was quite as prudently conservative
then as he is now
and wrote us candidly and and and with
us with with as much conviction
or robert nisbet often mentioned in
conjunction with these latter-day new
conservatives was one of the more
conspicuous of us original the
conservatives
with the publication of his principal
book the quest for community in 1953
but i digress
this spell record essence of
conservative thought at the end of the
40s in the beginning of the 50s was
paralleled chronologically by the
decline and fall of the new deal
democrats and the abrupt descent of
dwight eisenhower to the grandest seat
among the seats of the mighty
but there was next to no connection
between
these two political phenomena except
they they both may have been provoked in
part by a general american boredom with
the cliches of the new deal and by the
obvious feebleness of what remained of
new deal measures
during the truman administration
arthur m schlesinger jr endeavored to
talk the new conservatives
for their failure to be appointed to
office by president eisenhower mr
selection german himself uranus always
after place
as the 18th century politics called it
politicians called it
but the writing
conservatives of the 50s were not
disconcerted by not having been
appointed eisenhower placement
some of the so-called conservatives were
democrats
and other of the republic of the
republicans among us
most had preferred robert taft to dwight
eisenhower
so far as we conservative writers had
anything in common it was this
we were social critics innocent of any
design for assuming personal power
for one thing we set our faces against
political centralization
so that a cushy appointment in
washington would have been repudiating
of our own convictions
we were sufficiently ignored by both
republican and democratic presidents
except that richard nixon did
occasionally invite one or another of us
to the white house for general
conversation
now and
then a united states senator or a member
of the house rare birds like
representative crane here might send one
of us say no of appreciation
we fared no better among state
politicians
we had no central apparatus
few publishers approved our books
the great foundations rarely assisted us
in the academy
we were a forlorn remnant
still we were not ignored by the movers
and shakers of public opinion
i owe my job to the new york times
that is to gordon chalmers cultural
review of the conservative mind in the
pages of the new york times book review
the publication in those days less
doctrinaire and more interesting than it
is today
uh time followed by devoting time
magazine followed by devoting its entire
book review section on july 4th to the
conservative mind
and other
influential journals
of large circulation fell into line
once my book had made a breach in the
ramparts liberals watched
other authors fought their way to robert
in robert nisbet
uh thomas molnar james kilpatrick
frederick williamson robert fitch
somewhat later in a standing hog and
jeffrey hart in a score of others we
were allied to with older men some of
whom had been very different in their
politics at an earlier time writers like
james burnham william henley chamberlain
john davenport and john and john
chamberlain
professors like leo strauss will herberg
ross hoffman and eliseo vivas
milton friedman and a few other american
economists of a cast more or less
conservative already had weight early in
the 50s we've made ourselves heard
the breach in the liberals literary
ramparts has been closed since then
but the liberal reviewers have not yet
succeeded altogether in stamping out the
forlorn hope of conservative writers who
penetrated within the citadel in the
fifties
they're sprang up conservative weekly
and quarterly magazines and some few
book publishers besides henry regnary
began to indulge us occasionally
more wondrous still now and again people
of conservative bit actually were
permitted to speak on campuses
they were organized a young people's
action group young americans for freedom
the national campus discussion society
distinctly conservative now called the
intercollegiate studies institute
both organizations have outlasted the
belligerent student clubs radical clubs
in the sixties and seventies
these were large gains if one had an eye
to the future
now of course this haphazard
intellectual revival of conservative
thought
affected american elections only little
in this land i repeat it takes a long
while for new or revived
political concepts to supplant in
citizens conscious and subconscious
minds
accustomed
political loyalties and
prejudices still the immediate influence
of the conservative renewal would have
been larger had not certain political
accidents occurred
i refer to the extravagances of joseph
mccarthy
the absurdities of the john birch
society and the murder of president
kennedy
the fiasco of barry goldwater's
presidential campaign and then johnson's
vietnam war
despite our protestations the liberal
and radical publicists carried us
conservatives with these alien brushes
even so the public opinion polls showed
a steady increase
in the number of americans who set
themselves down as conservatives
indeed from the first poll onward
conservatives formed the largest single
element of political preference in
america
combining circumstances and an altered
climate of opinion or published pushing
public opinion toward conservative
measures
the circumstances which worked upon
american public opinion
were obvious enough during the past 30
years and are still more obvious just
now
inflation of the currency
burdensome taxation
oppressive
political centralization
sorry confusion in the public schools
disintegration of great cities by social
change
violent crime feebleness and failure
foreign affairs
these are only some of the afflictions
concerning which american citizens
became uncomfortably aware
from the end of the second world war
onward
though particularly during the johnson
administration
listed foreign affairs last among these
concerns incidentally because the
american democracy interests itself and
foreign affairs
only when disaster is at hand
because of these political
administrations president liberal were
in power while these grim troubles came
to pass
and because liberal dogmas dominated the
serious press and the universities
quite justly the american public tended
to look upon look for some alternative
to liberal slogans and policies
never has any very large proportion of
the american electorate embraced a
thoroughgoing radicalism
therefore conservative measures slowly
were recognized by the public as the
alternative to liberal measures
this realization it seems to me is about
to produce conservative men and measures
this autumn
always of course barring political
accidents
adverse circumstances alone do not bring
on a reformation or renewal for people
to take arms against the sea of troubles
there must be provided the catalyst of
ideas
for good or ill
about 1950
the emerging conservative thinkers had
perceived the character of national
national adversity
long before the general public became
aware of the difficulties in which the
united states was sliding
thus a measure of conservative
imagination and right reason already
existed as the public rather slowly and
efficiently began to turn its back upon
the politically dominant liberalism
a handful of conservative writers and
scholars and those public men capable of
serious reflection offered an
alternative to the exploded dogmas and
measures of liberalism
those renewed or fresh conservative
ideas which can have consequences
worked upon the public's discontent with
the circumstances into which liberalism
had brought the country
this union of thought and circumstance
brought about the present conservative
movement
well at this point we require some
definition
any intellectual and political movement
if it is to achieve more than an
ephemeral popularity and influence
must possess a body of common belief
i don't mean that it must or should
possess an ideology
as h stuart hughes wrote once
conservatism
is the negation of ideology conservatism
is the negation of ideology
ideology is
political fanaticism and illusion
as john adams defined it ideology is the
art of diving and sick and sinking and
sinking in politics the science of
idiocy
instead i mean by a body of common
belief
those general convictions and healthy
prejudices
derived from long consensus and social
experience
such a body of common belief still
exists in america
perhaps more than any other land
here are some of its elements persuasion
that there exists a moral order of more
than human contrivance which we ought to
conform human laws and customs as best
we can
confidence in the american constitution
both the written constitution and the
underlying unwritten constitution of
tested usage and custom
attachment to representative government
suspicion of central direction in most
matters
preference for an economy in which work
and thrift obtain the just rewards
love of country and love which extends
beyond the present moment to the past
and the future of the country
and there are other elements which have
not lost their vitality
now these are conservative beliefs and
impulses
their roots are not only the withered
i have sketched the origins of this body
of common belief in my book the roots of
american order
this being still the common american
patrimony even though of course the
average citizen could not express these
beliefs very coherently
it is not surprising that in a time of
tribulation and discontent
the american public begins to listen to
conservative voices
in short this present hour is an hour of
conservative opportunity
the conservatives of the united states
have made large gains already
indeed it is possible now to speak of a
movement
even if of a movement still confused and
disunited
30 years ago there existed no
organizations like the heritage
foundation and its intellectual journal
policy review
or other present organizations and
serious journals of a conservative cast
thirty years ago it did not seem
conceivable that two economists
believing in a free economy would be
awarded nobel prizes
thirty years ago nothing was more
improbable in politics than that both
great national parties would be inclined
toward nominating for the presidency
uh those aspirants which would seem the
more conservative of the lot
yet the fact remains that this
conservative movement does not march in
lockstep
in one respect the lack of unanimity is
a virtue it means that conservatives are
no ideologues
uh they believe in diversity and
individual opinions
utopianism oddly and extreme positions
nevertheless
are
our eutopianism and oddity and extreme
positions are not conservative virtues
those failings are easily easily
discerned in various aspects and
factions
of the conservative drift rather
clumsily labeled conservative
but let me
touch briefly upon some of these
excesses of what is
called the conservative movement
one of them is the consent is a
continuing obsession particularly among
some people well endowed with the good
with the goods of fortune
with economics
i don't mean to denigrate the dismal
science
a good economic system has produced
america's prosperity
and still more important it is closely
connected with america's general private
liberty
those simple libertarians who somehow
fancy that we can reconcile an extreme
of personal freedom with a servile and
directed economy simply do not
understand the great mysterious
incorporation of the human race
and as samuel johnson put it a man is
suddenly suddenly more innocently
occupied the money is engaged in making
money
yet economic activity is not no more the
whole of the civil social order
than wealth is the sole source of
happiness
economic success is a byproduct
not the source of america's success as a
society
the sort of ignorant understanding to
which i refer every illustrated by one
of the inevitable antidotes of
eric
ladine
on one occasion that compulsive traveler
was addressing a gathering of catholic
businessmen in detroit
at the conclusion at the conclusion of
his remarks a gentleman in the audience
inquired
doc
do you know what history is
why no kundalini replied can you
instruct me
sure
history is just economics that's all
just economics
in the mind's eye one may see the ironic
la deen replying
indeed
tell me sir are you a catholic
sure i just made a novena
what a pity sir what a pity
why is it a pity i'm a catholic this
belligerently why because sir if you're
another catholic you might be made a
professor at the marx london institute
to embrace marxist materialism and
determinism in the name of an of another
abstraction called capitalism is
delivered to deliver oneself bound to
the foe
conservatives do defend a free economy
they defend it however is bound up with
a complex social structure of order and
justice and freedom
founded upon an understanding of man as
a moral being
to reduce ourselves to economic
determinism
uh
economic determinants offering
sacrifices to the great god to mammon is
to the rule is to ruin the prospects of
us all
now sometimes allied with this economic
obsession is the mode of belief which
calls itself libertarian
i willingly concede that there exists
some very sensible and honorable men and
women who allow themselves to be tagged
that label
but both fa hayek and your servant
reject the term
and we have our reasons as men who have
learned considerable from burke and
tocqueville
these reasons as applied to current
controversies have been sufficiently
detailed recently in national review by
ernest vandenhout
let me say here only a few words by way
of general principle
any good society is endowed with order
and justice and freedom
of these as sir richard livingston wrote
order has primacy
for without terrible order existing
neither justice nor freedom can exist
to try to exalt an abstract
liberty to a single solitary absolute as
jon stewart mill attempted is to
undermine order and justice
and in a short space to undo freedom
itself
the real prescriptive freedom of our
civil social order
license they mean when they cry liberty
in john milton's phrase
now john adams and john tito caroline
carried out a correspondence about the
nature of liberty
liberty as an abstraction adam said in
substance
is either
meaningless or painful
there is the liberty of the wolf
and there is a very different liberty of
the civilized human being
we owe our american freedoms to a
well-functioning civil social order that
requires duties as well as liberties for
its survival
so i find it really amusing to behold
extreme libertarians
who proclaim that they would abolish
taxes military defense and all
constraints upon impulse
obtaining massive subsidies from people
whose own great influence
has been made possible only with the
good laws and superior constitutions of
these united states
and by our armies and navies keep in
check the enemies of our order and
justice and freedom
there is no freedom in anarchy
even if we call anarchism anarchism
libertarianism
if one demands unlimited liberty
as in the french revolution
one in one ends with unlimited tyranny
men have been temperate mind never can
be free edwin burke tells us
their passions forge their fetters
some momentary encounters become images
that fix our future thought
when a college freshman debating in
indianapolis i happened to stroll into
the great railway station in that city
now being converted into something else
with federal money
uh with my freshman colleagues
uh and we watched from high above the
intricates
high above the intricate shuttling of
long trains in and out of the station
because my father was a
railroad benjamin
i understood what care precision and
complex scheduling necessarily were
involved below
the functioning of a railway station
like the functioning of the american
economic apparatus generally
like the functioning indeed of the whole
american society
was dependent upon a wondrously high
degree of duty discipline and complex
coordination
i pointed out to my companions that
inevitable truth
the libertarians still have not had not
grasped that point
it was well for the safety enjoyed by
railway passengers that my father and
other railway men were not libertarians
they did not permit their private
interests such as a glass of beer to
conflict with their duties
yet those railway men that were free men
not ashamed of the american constitution
well some of the people who style
themselves libertarian i repeat do in
fact subscribe to the body of common
beliefs i mentioned earlier
what's in the name
actually they remain conservative enough
but as for for those documented
libertarians who stand ready to sweep
away government in the very moral order
why that way lies madness
if the american public is given the
impression that these fantastic dogmas
represent american conservatism then
everything we have gained over the past
three decades may be lost
the american people are not about to
submit themselves to the utopianism of a
tiny band of chirping secretaries whose
profit
even though they may not have much
direct acquaintance with his works or
jean-jacques rousseau
if they have to leave this country
conservatives must appear to be and in
fact be
imaginative but reasonable people who do
not proclaim that they will turn the
world upside down genuine conservatives
know that man and society are not
perfectable
they are realistically aware that utopia
including the dream paradise of absolute
unfettered liberty to act just as the
person pleases
means literally nowhere
it is one of the conservatives principal
functions to remind mankind that
politics is the art of the possible
these these united states are entering
upon an epoch necessarily of sweeping
but prudent reform
a conservative task
the diplomatic and military policies of
the liberal era have brought us to an
imminent peril
the economy is virtually static while
inflation and taxation consume the seed
court of capital
the educational structure is decayed and
ineffectual
our great cities have become dangerous
and dismal
political centralization reduces local
and private responsibility and
opportunity
the american people generally have been
disheartened
what the public hopes for however dimly
is restoration
a renewal of american intelligence vigor
confidence a regaining of order freedom
and justice
if conservatives can deal with these
great problems ably and honesty
posterity will bless them
it has happened from time to time in the
history of civilizations
that a period of decadence and
discouragement has been followed by a
period of renewal and hope
it can be so with our american
civilization
such a restoration requires the joining
of right reason
with imagination
but the people in the present
conservative movement possess such
reason and imagination
or our conservatives generally what john
stuart mill called them
the stupid party
certainly a good many folk who are
called conservative are dull or
apathetic merely
admittedly a good many folk who call
themselves conservative seem interested
chiefly in serving their own advantages
with the conservative populations
brooks adams wrote
slaughter is nature's remedy he meant
that mere plotting adherence to old ways
will not suffice for survival in an age
of fierce and rapid change
yet it is not the conservatism of
dullness and short-sighted self-interest
merely which has been stirring in this
country
polymer moore remarked that in a time of
crisis
often the conservative displays powers
of imagination which saved the day
we need to rouse the imagination of that
sort
even the poetic imagination
as i told some of you on my last
occasion here president nixon once asked
me what one book he should read
t.s eliot's notes towards the definition
of culture i told him and later sent him
a copy
with elliot and other great poets the
conservative the imaginative
conservative takes long views
and he knows among a good many other
things that culture
is more than a matter of subsidized art
festivals
it is our culture itself which tatters
these concluding 20 years of the 20th
century
the word conservative originally
signified
guardian
today thinking conservatives have to be
concerned with more than winning
elections important though that task is
we have to think about think seriously
about our civilization's preservation
thinking always being painful
liberals and radicals have not troubled
themselves much about the shape of
things to come
during those 30 years of growth of the
conservative movement immense mischief
has been done to the politics and the
economics and the culture of this
country
soon it may be up to conservatives to
repair the damage if they know how
what commenced is a rearguard action by
some of the older generation of men of
politics and business
as a troubled protest against the
mindless draft of affairs by a handful
of scholars and writers
may find itself invested with national
authority
are conservatives well prepared for this
responsibility
no not all together
but then time moves on and nobody ever
is well prepared for great duties
and the longer we we delay the more
vulnerable become the nation's
difficulties
those of us who began a conservative
intellectual renewal about 1950
have grown great in opposition to
liberal dominations and powers
we don't expect to be ever to be able to
doze secure a noticed land
we are not yet the passing generation
another 20 years must elapse before my
eldest child is as old as i was when i
published my first book and i was then a
young writer
so it was not a case of to you from
failing hands we throw the torch
the heritage foundation i trust will be
here or at least somewhere in the
district
uh by the first year of the 21st century
supposing the conservative men and
majors have renewed this republic
and quite conceivably i may be with you
on
june 4 dominion 2000 reporting on the
progress of the conservative movement
uh prudent change is the means of our
preservation
and the great statesman is one who
combines with this who combines a
disposition to preserve with an ability
to to improve
that awareness and that sort of person
the conservative movement has been
endeavoring to develop
our efficacy may be put to the test very
soon
if we fail
where else in the modern world will
power as a resistance and recuperation
be discovered
walter badgett says
conservatism is enjoyment
life is worth living the conservative
declares
we're not going to march to zion
yet we may succeed in planting some
trees in the wasteland
with burke
i attest the rising generation
i thank you for your patience
[Applause]
our next two speakers our commentators i
think will
add some lively insights and responses
to russell kirk
and i am very pleased to introduce you
now to our two commentators
they are respectively lewis lapham the
editor of harper's magazine
and congressman philip crane
mr lapham is not only the editor of
harper's but as many of you know
is the author of a regular column in
that journal
entitled from the easy chair
it's certainly one of my favorite
portions of harper's and one to which i
turn regularly every month
these
and other of his writings have recently
been published in a best-selling book of
essays entitled fortune's child
it's our delight this evening to welcome
louis lapham as our first commentator on
russell kirk's paper
[Applause]
mr fulmler i'm delighted to be here i
appreciate the
invitation dr kirk i'm
delighted to respond
congressman great
ladies and gentlemen
i'm going to go over this as i would go
over a
text and submitted to me as an editor so
what i will do in the first point is
just raise a few questions and uh then i
disagree with your imperation but we
will get to that at slow stages and
before i do that i would say that i
admire your writing and i'm delighted
with the
the style and the whip of it
however i i have very great difficulty
with understanding i still don't know
what a conservative is or what the word
means i've only heard it used as an
insult
and
the insult changes depending on the
context and the circumstances so i'm i'm
still not clear having read this piece
and having listened to the piece where
is the
fruition of ideas that's about to take
form
and i
i assume that most people are
conservative 99 of the time i mean most
people like order and regularity and
do all they can to repeat themselves
endlessly including
liberals which you've all
we can all score in but but i i think
it's a human trait not necessarily a
political one
on page two i would i would
be concerned about the notion that
serious thought trickles down from the
top of the hierarchy to the
basement
and uh it seems to me it works the other
way the best thought the most exciting
forces of imagination come up out of the
common experience and certainly if i was
dealing with homer or shakespeare or
socrates i would see it coming up rather
than trickling down in an orderly way
the
i'm making these small
points as i go through the paper
on page four we get to the point lionel
trilling that says until this renewal of
conservative thought at the end of the
1940s liberal dogmas and morals and
politics had been everywhere triumphant
in the united states since the 1920s
and i immediately think of the 1920s in
the south
terms of racial segregation
i think of prohibition
and i think of the
hardly liberal attitudes that prevailed
between men and women in the 1920s and
so forth so that to say that i've i have
never in my life seen liberal dogma and
morals and politics prevail anywhere
except in a rather artificial
intellectual
uh or governmental context not in
not as often in real life as one would
hope for
i go further and they say and we get to
the point about the breaching the
liberal
all of the press but the press to me is
very conservative again we get in the
matter of definitions but
i think of most of the magazines i'm
familiar with whether it's the national
review the new republic
commentary these are manned faithfully
by people of various kinds of
conservative persuasion
and so to my mind are the new york times
and the washington post most of which
seem to me to be
uh if anything uh reactionary rather
than uh liberal
the
maybe this is a matter simply of
definition and change of
words
then we get to the point that never has
any very large proportion of the
american electorate embraced a
thoroughgoing radicalism i think that's
probably true of any electorate the
american electorate is not
radical most people are not radical as
said before
the disaffection i mean we talk about
the
carter and reagan both of them being
more or less conservative people but the
disaffection with that seems to me clear
from the
polls
the dissatisfaction if anything i would
i would look at the present political
situation as a repudiation of
conservative notions
i would also look at the 20 million
dollars that governor connolly spent for
one vote
as a repudiation on
conservative value
the
um
i go further and finally on page 11
we come to such a body of common belief
still exists in the united states
perhaps more than and we get now to the
conservative common body of belief that
exists in the united states
one the persuasion that there exists a
moral order or more than human
contrivance to which we ought to conform
human laws and customs as best we can we
could also say that about the maharishi
about zen
about
the the southern baptist evangelical
cults
that could be
a very mindless and dangerous thing
indeed
we get to the point confidence in the
american constitution both the written
constitution and the underlying written
constitution i've met very few people in
my life who've ever read the
constitution
and i talked to reasonably educated
people and what passes for the
intellectual community in new york
we get to the
attachment to representative government
and yet we see that there is nobody's
bothering to go to the polls
the number dwindles every year
and representative government this
country has become more representative
in the states in the sense of stage play
people put on the ropes of office and
pretend to be the wind or something of
that sort that actually have control
over events rather than representative
in terms of constituency
we get to the point suspicion of central
direction and yet we have
a country that is
where in the worship of various
religious
ideas all of whom of course central
direction
is
paramount
same thing with the
general worship of wealth the country
the god mammon which we're coming to
later on in this tour
a preference for an economy in which
work and thrift obtain their just awards
i see very little evidence of that
in my experience i see something for
nothing being a predominant point of
view
you can just
witness the crowds and the gambling
casinos in new jersey or the amount of
money that is unreported in tax income
for the kinds of
people that want a dole of some kind or
another whether it's a dole and
direct transfer payment we're talking
about an economy that
fifty percent of it is a transfer
payment and we're not including the
donatives to the upper middle class
in terms of such things as public
broadcasting service
the
love of country which extends beyond the
present moment to the past and future of
the country we have no draft
even governor reagan a conservative is
backing away from the draft he talks
about the love of country on the other
hand he's not willing to
put his uh chips on that particular
table and also we have a you know we
have a point where
the the present moment
predominates in people's thinking
certainly this is certainly true of the
american press as a whole
um
and we get on to number page 13 and we
get to the point i'm just again raising
small points as we go through here these
are minor
editorial criticisms and i still haven't
come to my one other objection which is
the end but one point on page 13 as
samuel johnson put in a man is seldom
more innocently occupied and when he's
engaged in making money
i i would find that there are a lot of
loan sharks in new york that they are
not innocent people
neither was the shah of iran neither are
many of the multinational corporations
i'm afraid that mr johnson was
not quite at least my view of the world
accurate in that state
i also can quote
jefferson to you
i don't know whether he goes against the
grain of the conservative idea or not
but
a quotation from jefferson it follows
quote money not morality is the
principle of commercial nations
close quote
we then get on to page 13 and to reduce
ourselves to economic determinists and
so on and mammon
uh
i see that in many places and i think we
underestimate the great pleasures that
people take in the exercise of power and
the uses of corruption people actually
enjoy doing those things to other people
i mean it was the mistake in the united
states to think that all we had to do
was send henry combat lodge to southeast
asia
and people like uh two and so forth
would simply to see him was to want to
be like him
that is not true
east asian despots enjoy being best
spots they like to torture people
to see henry cabot lodge is not the one
to be and we have
there's this misunderstanding i think
the uh
i could go on but i see i'm running out
of time and i will just get to the final
point and the point that i would make
the argument that i would make on the
text as a whole is
that the united states is entering upon
an epoch of reform
i don't think so i think it's in the
middle of a revolutionary period
the revolution is going on in sciences
in politics communications
in many many different fields of
endeavor
and
it is an inner contradiction for a
conservative to talk on the one hand of
imagination and on the other hand of
reform if you have to if reform is the
task we don't need imagination we know
what we're doing and we simply can put
any in place but we don't know what
we're doing uh very few people that
myself included understand what the
how the world is changing and how
difficult and how complex the
combinations are
and this is a a revolutionary period of
time i think the next 20 years
and so we're not talking about paradise
lost
i mean just to talk here about american
culture to protect it and so forth and
so on and restore it there wasn't very
much american culture ever
there isn't much to protect to guard to
restore that you have to make it
and the whole point is are we going to
be able to make it
almost ex me hello i mean you know
there's been a lot of foundation work
it's just i mean it isn't there it
doesn't exist it has to be made it has
to be made every day
and and that is uh
that would be my central argument with
the
the beast and the other the others
are merely minor
cavals
[Applause]
the only conservative school of thought
that i could put you in i would say
would be the idiosyncratic school of
conservatives
which is a new vein that we will have to
perhaps invent at this point
our second discussion this evening
comes well equipped to
comment on professor kirk's paper
congressman phillip crane
graduate of hillsdale college phd from
indiana university in history
a
performer professor of history member of
congress from 1969 through the present
time
a member of the ways and means committee
a recent presidential
candidate for the republican
presidential nomination
and importantly to tonight's discussion
author of the 1964 book entitled the
democrats dilemma
which traced the fabian influence on the
u.s intellectual scene to that point
it's my pleasure to welcome phil crane
to the podium tonight
thank you
thank you very much ed dr kirk hello and
ladies and gentlemen back in the 50s i
returned to graduate school at indiana
university after a two-year hiatus in
the army in two years in the advertising
business upon completing registration at
the field house i walked out of the
building to be greeted by a number of
tables assembled by different campus
organizations soliciting membership
in front of one of these tables was a
six foot high cardboard back photograph
of eleanor roosevelt's head in black
letters above the photograph were the
words know your enemy
amused i strolled over to talk to the
students at the table they represented
the indiana university conservative
league this was a campus affiliate of
what was then known as the
intercollegiate society of
individualists now known as the
intercollegiate studies institute i had
never heard of the organization i
scanned their literature and was
delighted to discover that there were
eighteen thousand student members on
campuses throughout the united states
and roughly three hundred teaching
faculty members representing every
discipline in liberal arts the greatest
immediate lift i received from this
information was psychological to educate
for liberty was their motto in the six
years i'd spent in undergraduate school
and graduate school prior to this
experience i had become familiar with
such organizations as the fair play for
cuba committee the young socialist
alliance the young people's socialist
league but i was unaware of any
organization that provided a counter
poise and corrective to these public
nuisances on any campus say perhaps the
young republicans it was through isi
that i first became familiar with
russell kirk his book the conservative
mind had a profound impact on my
thinking
my childhood training made me
susceptible to such a work but i had
uh
how you figure the british comparison is
going to work out because there we've
had
a
conservative party which was far more
than anything
affected your republican party became an
eight artiste party as much as the
socialists were until about seven or
eight years four or five years ago
and has now become
as the mass of the people are
conservative in the sense which i think
mr lapham denied the americans had a
culture but as i feel it if they don't
um i've misunderstood the country there
is an unconscious conservatism
everywhere
deep
being unconscious doesn't mean shallow
in britain we have that we have the
leadership now conservative in your
sense but the mere weight of what i
think elliot said the
uh
above liberalism didn't he say something
like
the um
ideas only gain power when the
intellectuals stink
when they're dead
now the mere momentum is what i'm going
to ask we have in the conservative party
itself a vast momentum of ethicism of
liberalism in the
bad sense in your new sense
and also among
in westminster
as in georgetown
not what the people think not what the
leadership think not what the
intellectual battle has been won but the
momentum is very very powerful even in
england now how how much time have you
got is the question i was going to ask
about two minutes
oh
the unborn ages went out of my soul
uh
i don't know how
long we have
um
i long marveled of course at the
endurance of the
british conservative party the oldest
coherent political party in the world
really
and
living in britain much as i have one
time or another
and say traveling by train through
densely packed industrial districts
where a large part of the population
vote story
despite all the
afflictions of industrial age and the
all the socialist propaganda
still a an electrical england
majority uh still basically conservative
take away scotland and wales
who have a
substantial permanent majority of
conservatively inclined people who vote
conservative
uh in england
uh shows how deeply entrenched the
conservative impulse
is there after all these uh
this contents of our time and more
deeply entrenched than really than in
america
now
in america the conservative
impulse interest has been
shored up by the widespread diffusion of
property
uh from an early time
now large majority people in america are
really quite substantial property owners
most of them in the form of course of
houses
insurance policies bank deposits very
many and of course now stocks and bonds
and in short well what we have here what
has long been talked about in britain a
property-owning democracy
in which uh clearly the
radical impulses restrained by the
self-interest of
most of the electorate
uh which is this more time here and
makes uh
radical propaganda
provides a bulwark against radical
propaganda
um
whether there indeed there is a
we have the
intelligence and the
force of will
to resist the
totalitarian impulse of our time remains
to
to be seen
at least
resistance now is
imagination are stirring
thank you dr kirk once more
john o'sullivan the editor of policy
review
well my question is a development of uh
dr conquest and it's addressed to mr
lapham and to representative crane
because i think that mr dr kirk has more
or less answered it in that reply and
it's this a foreigner when he visits
america
imagines he's coming to a booming free
enterprise vigorous capitalist society
in which civil servants if they uh dare
to appear in public at all it will be
shabby creatures not to be seen in the
best restaurants now